bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ci siamo trovati
su che in tester
mi piace questa pronuncia è bellissima
questa seconda e più soldi ragazzi oggi
faremo dei videogame su clarence
clarence ma prima sigla
perfetto ragazzi siamo sul clarence
bombardier che bello la cosa più bella
della storia il fatto che non sappia
cucinare veramente un hamburger quindi
evita gli esclusi ea madonna che cucina
non ho letto non è fermi non ho fatto il
genk bel no ti stai muovendo rarissimo
complimento cioè una movenza fantastica
di fai capire come mi muovo sono
riuscito a farlo
qualcosa mi dice che era meglio se stavo
fermo effettivamente ragazzi ho scoperto
l'uso delle frecce della tastiera
prefetto che non avevo capito pardon
perfetto perfetto perfetto è più
difficile di quanto si creda davvero
posso assicurare era per allenamento
questo facciamo finta che non è
successiva successo niente adesso nati
ricominciavo tranquilli perfetto che poi
ecco armour hamburger formaggio
fantastico ragazzi nella vostra vita vi
auguro di non capitale mai in cucina con
ma neanche una volta con me siamo così
quella roba lì kiwi a no sono cetrioli
sono un genio come co come come faccia
con una persona sola come faccio a
prenderne due insieme spiegano in un os
x con che fisica ok ok ma arriva la
chiusa del panino devo continuare molto
no perché non è che anzi la stavo anche
mancata mazza non era un secondo di
tregua cielo a uno tipo l'intervallo a
scuola di ricreazione e da un secolo che
non muoio non dovevo dire la sta cosa
non solo però cos'era peperoncino mi sa
che dovevo effettivamente prezzi non
sapevo io lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo
ragazzi prova a non prendere nient'altro
sa tenere solo il peperoncino
nell'hamburger voglio vedere se riesco a
farmi così si sa i ragazzi hamburger al
peperoncino
c'è solo un peperoncino giuro che buono
sono cucina lo zio favi seriamente
ragazzi prevenite a casa mia
hamburger
non venite a casa mia proprio lasciate
perdere fate finta che non abbia detto
niente perché mandre non è male
riuscire a fare panini così c'è almeno
sai che non mangi più per un mese almeno
quello perfetto 2 pepe non ci sarebbe
però 4 cos'è sta roba
a me fanno veramente schifo i cetrioli
lega non è per influenzare qualcuno però
sempre e comunque meglio della dinamica
e si intenda ragazzi basta ho deciso mi
impegno ho deciso appunto che succede se
la blocca e ci ha capito che mi sto
impegnando e si è bloccato il gioco
fantastico ciò pian sia qui che
all'esame di maturità non impossibile
bene due ragazzi dove almeno almeno al 5
ci devo fare a meno che poi diventavano
hi tech e che si ferma diventa ancora
più difficile quello il problema
ancora una corona corona ma iniziano
battere il mio record di peperoncini
cosa sto schivando non avete idea perché
io parlo nelle teche perché io papà che
uso la mia lingua e l'andata ma non devo
usata lustre zitto qual è il mio
problema o ragazzi facciamo l'ultimo
tentativo poi lasciar perdere perché
evidentemente sono abbastanza negato per
questa cosa 34 fermi surf pausa pausa
spiegatevi che cos'è questo dopo
l'incredibile successo del mio hamburger
con un peperoncino abbiamo inventato
l'hamburger con quattro peperoncino è
proprio la gioia di vivere cioè tu lo
mangi e vai dai pompieri direttamente a
fuoco ragazzi e va bene va bene va bene
cioè questo è l'effetto che fa dopo che
ti sei mangiato hamburger con quattro me
peroncini cioè proprio esplodi grazie
devo la mia vita a clarence le mie i
miei futuri pasti e per questo
incredibile tutorial di cucina
ho cambiato video vieni ragazzo adesso
siamo sull'incredibile giornata di
clarence dopo essersi mangiato dei
panini consistenti con peperoncino di è
esploso letteralmente lo stomaco se
guardate bene si proverà a tutti i
giochi di aver daily non in una sola
incredibile giornata riuscirai a stargli
dietro guarda zio le ho saputo cucinare
degli hamburger quindi non colpisce a e
tipo guario sta cosa ok ho capito quindi
devo prendere le devo fare le cose in
tempo bellissimo sono un fenomeno si
giochi non vi preoccupate para cosa ho
preso fermi no mi sarebbe uno scherzo
non deficiente perché se magari non mi
esaltavo ce la facevo bene ho perso sono
un bravo a questo gioco non seriamente
fatto finta che questo pezzo di video
voi non abbiate visto proprio dei
cominciamo proprio come se non ci fosse
un domani arrampicate ok perfetto è il
primo andato ci siamo ragazzi posso fare
tranquilli trova e 2 che va bene e va
beh qualcosa sono un esploratore
raccogli non riuscivo a prendere la
pallina mi sentivo stupido sono stupido
non mi sentivo fi strike perfetto a
livello che alcuni sono difficilissimi
tipo con lo trovano nelle palline ad
altri sono semplicissimi ce l'aveva
farne una donna da un eccesso all'altro
passano clicca tempo amici miei sette i
migliori ballerini della storia fatemelo
dire ok per ragazzi siamo veramente la
il test del videogiocatore supremo
questo para questa volta non mi fa non
mi faccio intortare ecco perfetto era io
posso sempre perdere come un pirla
ragazzi io c'ho dei problemi nel
prendere le palle c'è seriamente
trascina perfetto perfetto tra i cinque
ragazzi record ai quasi record
anzi no è record assoluto ci sia una
specie di bost prima o poi o continuano
così a vita ricca tempo no cos'è oddio
ci ha sfasciato tutto schermo turno 17
vai vai vai vai vai me ne frega niente
mai spruzza
ho trovato mi sono esaltato di nuovo a
sei sposato io lo schermo cosa devo fare
cos'è aiuto il peso è non ha senso un
matto no no perché è il sommato senso ma
tutto lo schermo ho più visto niente non
vale così ragazzi proprio l'ultima volta
a battere il 19 ma riesco perché
credetemi ce la posso fare
facciamo spara spara un numero 27 arriva
27 a casa o colpisci ok no rega questo
non riesco a lui e ai ragazzi è successo
che ho cliccato per sbaglio su del
regular shout quindi mi è andato sulla
invece disegnando al su clarence è
andato sulle regole le cose che adoro di
clarence york che non ce la posso fare a
vedere sono le pose le pose check e
meraviglia io voglio una scultura di
clarence subito da velamento
sull'armadio davvero sono su cartoon
network ma la vera era figata
sto cercando di guardare il logo che sta
di cody qua non mi ricordo più uno dei
dalle due parti con che sopra il mio
dico adesso c'è il logo di cartoon
network mi sento come se fossi una
divinità eterna e bellissimo prima di
concludere ragazzi voleva nominare il
tempest air del mese come faccio tutti i
mesi quindi lo farò anche per il
prossimo mese ed in testa dello scorso
mese è enzo di zuclo quindi complimenti
enzo per aver vinto il primo posto la ge
in testa per il mese scorso e volevo
dirvi ragazzi se volete partecipare
anche voi a questo contest per essere il
nominati game testa del mese andate sul
sito di cartoon network che trovate qui
sopra il mio dito o qui sopra il mio
dito
uno dei due è riprendetevi in un
gameplay come faccio io ad esempio però
con il vostro stile quindi ognuno deve
provare a essere un po più se stesso e
che fa il video migliore verrà scelto
come game tester del mezzo nel prossimo
episodio vi raccomando siate più voi
stessi perché nello scorso contest mimì
siete sembrati tutti un po me ed era una
cosa un po strana quindi cercate di
tirare fuori cose vostre poi io lo
apprezzo veramente di più che i ragazzi
come episodio spero che video vi sia
piaciuto cose che se vi è piaciuto solo
punto è un mi piace anche a faccia di
facebook che nei video stata la
descrizione sono stati discreti ci
vediamo non posso evito i ragazzi mai
mai